this cycle difficulties will find
citation needed join me today you reads
books you know it's Chris Joel hail
everybody's favorite goes running down
runnin here's a thought
earlier today no led men's was entirely
naked
just imagine and stallion from a gray ah
Mountain South we'll see what hello I'm
not from Yorkshire give a little
improves me I've got a school from
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fact we get rise to point and a
ding and the special prize folks like
the good answers which is and today we
are talking about Julie door big
Automator
this is it so I came out of this frame
very well to be fair I am NOT French and
English I pronounce this as two or big
me but I think it's door Denis door but
all being no no yes
better known as Mademoiselle mapa more
power
it's a French article I'll be honest
it's downhill from here
the whole thing is I'm French is it no
it no listener yes ma upin
pif Mopar pop I'm not like I'm Ally more
pie
was she a mistress of louis xiv it's a
long list if it is born to Gaston dog me
a secretary to the master of the horse
for King Louie de 14 okay no close
enough to have a point but yeah it's a
good tree for a horse would you do it
down I'm ready but Sir I know it's very
sad but why the long face Hey
you're absolutely right that she was a
mistress but two accounts only viewpoint
for that the cat hold our mistress
French names count dominic ha
dominant endured has now gone well but
oh wow diarrhea
God became a mistress by the age of
fourteen pre French Revolution um but by
that point she had learned a lot of
things by learning alongside the court
pages okay is that an artful euphemism
no it's not unless you from ism know her
father trained the court pages so what
did Julie learn alongside words I'll
give you a point about reading Rudin's
that being very still going along at the
right moment when the King comes in yeah
I'll Hollister polishing pointy bits of
gold chair there's a couple of other
skills that are paid you would have in
those days carrying things some filling
things down something a little more
violent pudding yeah yeah which is an
altitude from ism she learned to thanks
and then dressed as a boy from an early
age she gone Bob with an assistant
fencing master the police were then
looking for him to arrest him what had
he done you know got a sword in his hand
yeah you know wears it around in a
violent fashion mmm did he perchance and
taking a punt did he stab someone
yeah I mean he I'm looking for something
specific here why might what might be a
reason for stabbing someone for being
slightly upset in which case you would
do what would you have a girl you know
what if you'll yes the man she was
involved with killed a man in a legal
duel so they fled the city to Marseille
how did she earn her living on the way
south fighting for money yes
by giving fencing exhibitions also
singing she's a talented singer singing
I'm fencing at the same time be a hell
of an act wouldn't it opera which I
believed had been invented at that point
I'm not only that she joins not for
company haha
[ __ ] all operatic effective she died a
tuberculosis at the end we've seen very
different versions of Aida made it to
Marseille through bored of her give it
sadly robot of this humdrum dull life of
opera singing and fencing decide to
become an accountant yes if you run away
somewhere but you can't you ran away
with someone too nice with a Matthew
from nice bet you are wrong about nice
and you're also wrong about man without
honor
yeah from a place that isn't nice not
giving you a point for that Avignon so
yeah ah I'm gonna bet but she was
running away because the girl was sent
away by her parents where was the other
girl sent to a convent yes that's all
right so she followed entering the
convent and with swords let's play so
you get in most places if you turn away
be sorted out no no she she went in to
comment and then tried to free her lover
from the convent this is elephant
operated saving really I like think that
everybody's singing all the way through
this yeah I do full of Rodgers and
Hammerstein could we talk through the
plan the scheme that she went through
the heist that she pulled it's quite a
dark heist it is yes her and her lover
out of the convent
what did the nuns have swords but uh not
to my knowledge
one barbarian
right hand side er up three then it
should have been a very easy heist GG
give me my chopped it all to pieces yeah
yeah it doesn't negotiate in fact things
go it's normally so exactly I thought
while they were trying to cover their
tracks what kind of scheme would you
pull to do that you would pretend to be
a doctor and you'd say this nun has a
terrible disease all of you will get the
disease she must come with me
immediately and the nuns would go oh a
doctor has said so there yeah then the
doctor would also have a sword and they
yeah and they were listening because he
was seeing you and then we have the
interval laughs the way ago yeah yeah ah
no he would pretend to be a policeman
I'd be a terrible crime
oh no he first come with me she was
charged in absentia for kidnapping
body-snatching and arson
so based on that that was the height Oh
so you take a dead body replace your
lover with it then burn the whole place
down to cover the tracks damn don't
worry me that your mind went straight to
this care was a confession there's no
DNA evidence darling she escaped from
that are the affair lasted three months
before the girl returned to her family
and then she left for Paris what
happened in Paris I'm deliberately
finding that vaguely because it's kind
of a repeat did she dig up the entire
marathon or a piece of something we've
already talked about something with odds
yes justice sword things in the stadium
get yes capture strophic juggling action
oh did she challenge someone to a duel
yes you're absolutely right she was
insulted by a young nobleman fought a
duel with him
put a blade through his shoulder Oh
awesome
well he pinned to a tree in a car hahaha
not a witch just a vicious injury go
that's the cartoon thing where I go well
this is inconvenient I'm just a picture
this Trina fight with your arm yes cause
thing about jewels um dueling is really
addictive Bismarck I think when he was a
student he was also addicted to dueling
and he would walk out on fares Oh 6:12
teen inch guns against the matter
well kind of like he'd walk around the
street wearing two to cudgels pistols
and two swords in a dressing gown anyone
around going here fight me fight me us
of 11 different Big Lebowski isn't it
during once it got lighter was a really
formerly backed
yes like they would what would they be
wearing you normal you seen it in a
shirt on here as I understand oh we're
talking much looking for this at least
much later this is
German military 19th century Oh you full
kit no doubt are moving armor have armor
don't you have a breastplate the sort of
early German thing that you dueled
growing up or you fence growing up to
get good oh yeah you are
yeah yeah yes you're absolutely right
they would fight with a mask and a thick
scarf or thick so you could only get
this that you could only get that bit
law it was essentially ritual
scarification awesome scars were judged
by Otto von Bismarck to be a sign of
bravery and men's courage could be
judged in as quote here by the number of
scars on their cheeks no cracking it II
spent on why was she how did you what I
just got this running joke I fell open
oh I see I got a very wrong idea about
this to two men backing up against each
other with a sword kind of thing with
the only high end of the sword would go
thunk the other one will go this month
of Bismarck so then it's dressing-gown
could your hand grenades and caliber
personnel reverses around the corner
well we're doing it this way very refer
you beaten by a worthy adversary which
but it says other guys got a cannon up
there yes I'm scars were usually targets
to the left profile okay I'll look at
you in your now I'm handsome for 19th
century warring Germany I will take that
I was explain the haircut and the pickle
Halbert can we have a picture that good
across the bottom of the screen I said
do not try this at home I think that
someone has insulted you and you want
the doodle in which case that's fine but
remember we mean the other cheeks yeah
so yes going back so pre French
Revolution back to Julie who yes who was
not you in fact who dueled by by
stabbing someone with a sword
this isn't sound much like a duel this
maja sounds like a very quick stabbing
she was a very good duelist by all
accounts well excellent officer here uh
he was Louis Joseph
but loins the son of the Duke of loins
he killed my father
prepare to die quite the opposite my
father a more general term it was it was
more that they they certainly want
enemies after this is there more about
the - just before the undisguised is
there more about him other than this
incident because I won't hate to be
myself the most people in history only
remembered as being the guy that got
stabbed through a shoulder potentially
stuck to a tree by that later pretended
to be a nun who sang opposite burnt the
convent down because that's not a great
way if you remembered let's face it but
one thing you can't write all that on
just the one tombstone that I know is
not another reference in here this
appears to the one reference to a man in
history how do they remember me are you
kidding come on well if it hadn't been
that he would have been remembered for
being the innately hilarious son of the
Duke of Lloyd yeah I'm probably
mispronouncing I'm choosing to believe
your luy NES of very French speakers in
here who can join long delays long
there's no advance from the audience but
what happened after that a three year
after he recovered by the way and after
he sent his apologies oh good man I'm
actually went out quite frequently for a
while McAfee did his golf take some time
to recover was there physiotherapy
involved it is back to sodding as an
artless euphemism kids they marry your
clogs are they never married but they
became lovers and later lifelong friends
okay Oh
remember that time I stabbed you in the
shoulder oh that's how we met the thug
works for me yeah I'm gonna point out
she is still in her late teens at this
point we are not in the section yet that
says adult-like Oh
you know when you're at home and you
think to yourself how is my life going
do you ever hear articles like this and
thing I have not achieved enough but I
was late seized by nineteen at no point
that I tried to burn a convent down with
a corpse inside it she is somewhere
between 17 and 20 at this point II knows
all about that yeah she was hired by the
Paris Opera in full knowledge but she
was pretty handy while she was doing it
I know as a doorman oh he might just mid
when she got a point at the Opera the
CRB check she must have had when he got
in what do we have well a little bit of
shoplifting my new right well sure
that's all done now burning down a
convent and stealing a body but to burn
down said convent now that we've not yet
only she only set the room on fire
she didn't burn down the entire con oh
that's all right then five years later
she's still raw cacao you see food oh
thank you thank you for those though the
facts as a society ball ah there was a
scandal turned up there's a bloke left
with a woman reverted to being a woman
burned the place down when somebody said
I one of those things is right but it
was a broad abroad
yeah blunderbuss attempt right so that's
let's try gary singing off for a throw
sword stabs man room on fire
none of those huh so based on those two
come on well she pretended to be a
doctor if you went around the ballroom
going everyone here has been terrible
disease come without you while I like in
my imagination she's dressed as an opera
singer she's got sword down each leg so
she's a bit stiff in walking and as a
stethoscope you actually said vaguely
the right words I she kissed a young
woman at a society ball uh what happened
immediately after that she had a deal
with the entire society ball yeah she
was challenged to jewels by three
separate noblemen so to be a point why
did she do that night of beat them all
in jewels
what was illegal in Paris at that point
fueling more than two people than
anything it was considered greedy just
dueling in particular so she now has to
flee Paris because she's also wanted
there I'd say makes a Marseille now I
think we're going there I think she went
to Marseille Brussels ah rejoins the
Opera and the final years of her career
here was spent in a relationship with uh
well who anyone brave enough Madame la
marquise de France are again butchering
all the French in here yeah well that's
what she was doing with the souls to be
honest that takes time so ugly for the
jury on her death she was inconsolable
she retired from the Opera and then took
refuge we're not a convent she died at
the age of 33 have no known grave and is
a legendary figure that windowed
interested gentle tap on it out of there
a point of a sword just so at the end of
the show congratulations will you in the
front you win a Greek philosophers
Mexican salamander speed control ah it
is all Aristotle actually lost or
something softly yes iris not like
Psilakis Russell congratulations will
with that we say thank you to Chris Joel
hey hey the gang Brandon so we'll see
look
I'll just um start we'll see you next
time good night
[Applause]
you
you
you